somebody else is not smiling this
morning the closest confidant to turn
against President Trump is going to
prison Michael Cohen mr. Trump's former
lawyer will serve time behind bars even
though he told his story to prosecutors
a judge also ordered Cohen to pay nearly
two million dollars in penalties and
another friend of the president is now
cooperating prosecutors say the
publisher of the National Enquirer
agreed to talk about paying hush money
to cover up an alleged sexual affair for
the president Paula Reed was at the
courthouse in Manhattan for Cohen's
sentencing it was quite a morning
yesterday Paula good morning it was
quite a morning a good morning in court
yesterday Cohen said he felt it was his
duty to cover up the president's quote
dirty deeds Nocona had hoped his
cooperation with the government would
spare him jail time and he just shook
his head in disbelief as the judge read
his sentence Michael Cohen left federal
court in New York we're inside moments
earlier Cohen learned living on his
former boss will not spare him a
three-year sentence in federal prison
for crimes including financial fraud and
lying to Congress the judge told Cohen
his veritable smorgasbord of crimes were
motivated by personal greed and ambition
Cohen at times close to tears apologized
and said blind loyalty to mr. Trump led
me to choose a path of darkness over
light in August Cohen pleaded guilty to
helping candidate Trump orchestrate
payouts at the height of the 2016
campaign including one - former Playboy
Playmate Karen McDougal and the tabloid
newspaper National Enquirer which bought
and then suppressed details of her
alleged affair with mr. Trump Cohen
recorded conversations with mr. Trump
allegedly discussing one of those
payments prosecutors revealed yesterday
they struck a deal not to charge the
Enquirer's parent company ami for its
involvement in exchange
ami admitted that it's principal purpose
in making the payment was to suppress
the woman's story to prevent it from
influencing the election in March
mcdougal said ami approached her when it
was clear mr. Trump would win the
Republican nomination they wanted to
squash the story
you're saying they wanted to protect
Donald Trump I'm assuming so yeah but at
the White House on Wednesday when
reporters asked about Cohen mr. Trump
ignored their questions and continued to
walk out the president's lawyer Rudy
Giuliani told me yesterday that he
believes Cohen is a liar and not a very
good one at that but while Giuliani has
claimed for months that investigations
into the campaigns are wrapping up we
learned yesterday the president's legal
troubles are far from over so let me ask
you about the National Enquirer because
the head of Ami David peckers a longtime
friend of the president's what is his
cooperation now mean for president Trump
this is a big problem for the president
because right now the president and his
lawyers they're arguing that these
payments to alleged mistresses had
nothing to do with a campaign but here
is part of this plea deal
am I the parent company of the National
Enquirer admits that its chairman was
meeting with the campaign promising to
help suppress stories in an effort to
help then candidate Trump get elected so
this helps to bolster prosecutors claim
that this could have been it campaign
finance violation have you heard why mr.
pecker to be honest point is cooperating
because he is a longtime friend of
Donald Trump's why has he decided I'm
gonna now turn over on you I mean it
just seems like good legal counsel that
you'd give any sort of client right if
given the stakes here it seems it seems
like a very good way to proceed to admit
to your wrongdoing to cooperate we all
remember that video of the President on
Air Force One answering the question of
whether or not he knew about this
payment yeah that's a bald well it's on
tape be honest yeah I don't know Paula
thank you